but okay so what else do you have
because I want to answer your questions
do you have anything else yeah and my
last question is why do you guys like um
just hold the images in your you know in
your um like the the Virgin she's asking
like why do you guys hold the Virgin
Mary or like images of Saints or like
why do you guys carry them like or
parade them around it's the same thing
if I ask you if I open up your phone
will I see pictures of people you love
uh yeah but I don't have to do that you
know I don't have to do that even
catholic's not forced to do it but what
I want to just instead of jumping just
patient with me so if I open up your
iPhone will you have pictures of your
husband or whoever it is and pictures of
them yeah but I don't carry them and
then just make people you carry them in
your phone you do yes if you have an
iPhone you're carrying them have you
ever kissed the picture when you miss
your loved one who's not with you no so
if you have a picture of your mommy
who's passed away you don't look at it
say oh I miss you mommy you've never
done that no she'll be in my heart but I
don't need to have a picture of her oh
so you don't have a picture of her so if
I come to your house I I can't have a
picture but it's not necess to remember
her do you have a picture of your mother
my mom does have a picture of her mom
has she passed away uh no both she does
she have a picture of a loved one that's
passed away uh G is uh
yeah May yeah oh my our dog our dog poor
dog yeah I hope you don't kiss that
picture man because I don't know if dogs
are in heaven
anyway when you have pictures of people
uhuh it's because those pictures are
there out of remembrance of them because
they are near and dear to your heart so
when I have a picture of my daughter and
I kiss
it I know that's not her but I'm kissing
it because because that picture is a
reminder of her and by kissing it I'm
showing myself to myself that I love
this person whom I cannot hold so that's
the first thing the statues that back
then they didn't
have cameras or iPhones so what they
would have to do is make depictions of
people that they love in order to be
visible reminders of these people who
are near and dear to their heart so if
you having pictures of people you love
kissing them is not idolatry don't
condemn these early Christians who
didn't have iPhones and didn't have
cameras so they could take actual
pictures of the actual person for then
making drawings or statues of people
whom they loved and were near dear to
their heart because God honored them and
praised them in the scriptures as
visible reminders of them because most
people at that time were illiterate they
could not
read they couldn't read it was a
illiterate Society so how would they be
reminded oh here's an image of the
Blessed Mother as a reminder in front of
them and if kissing them meant that
they're sinning then when you kiss a
picture of anyone you love your dog
you're an idolator you're a pagan and
why do you have a picture of a dog
that's something on
Earth why do you have a picture of your
dog didn't they say no images of
anything on Earth last time I checked a
dog is on Earth why do you have picture
of your dog I don't have a picture of my
dog only I have cats I have pictures
like why do you have pictures of your
cats there they things on earth didn't
say no images stuck a lot it's just for
fun and it's not in any way to just for
fun so God said you could have pictures
of things on her just for
fun it's it's it doesn't have any any
any it doesn't have any like a uh like
having a picture or not having the
picture is not going to make a
difference you're making it even worse
so if it's not important have a picture
so then why do you have
it for fun it does oh so it's okay so
when he saiding before God God it was
just for fun even says no images
anything on Earth it was just for fun so
if I go with your interpretation of
Exodus 20 you're gonna cause a lot of
problems for yourself secondly I'm gonna
ask you I'm gonna walk you through this
do you guys watch movies of Jesus
Jesus's
life yes we do but how do you know what
Jesus looks like no it's just something
that is I mean nobody knows it's just oh
but then why you watch movies of actors
that don't look like the real Jesus or
the real Mary so aren't you
sinning yeah I mean it's just you're
sinning okay no no no it's symbolic we
don't really know how they oh so it's
okay to watch
cartoons that have images of Jesus Mary
which we don't know what they look like
or movies where actors are playing Jesus
and Mary and they don't look anything
like the real Jesus or Mary that's okay
but if I have an icon a picture of Mary
or a statue of Mary or Jesus now that's
sin interesting it's because the problem
is not is not the image the problem is
that the what there was the problem
that's the people yeah well the people
because when you see a movie you the the
purpose is knowing the life of Jesus
right you're not that is the purpose so
when I see a statue of Jesus I won't be
reminded of his life but the purpose of
the image is that okay then but then a
lot of people you know as the images for
miracles because I was there and I was
not the you know why they asked the
image for the miracle you want I explain
it to you because they believe if they
go to that image representing that
person and when then they address that
image they know that image is not that
person but what they're believing is
when God sees that they are going to an
image of let's say Mary and they're
honoring that image because it's Mary
and they know that's not Mary but it's
reminding of a Mary and then they're
asking Mary to pray for them they
believe because of their love for the
mother who's
alive just like when you kiss a picture
of your mother they're believing that
Mary who by the grace of God is made
aware of it will then pray for them no
one's stupid enough to think that image
is Mary I don't think that's Mary but
what I'm doing is when I show it respect
I'm showing God see because this is an
image of your mother I'm showing respect
to show you that I love and respect your
mother who's my
mother yeah I understand that but it's
not only Mary it's images of many Saints
do you know you're not related anybody
that's the same principle though that's
my point it's the same
principle same principle when I go to a
picture of St sherel I believe that man
was a holy Man Who Loved God who is a
mighty soldier of God whom God worked
miracles through so when I have an image
of him when I show respect to the image
I know that's not him but I'm doing to
show God I recognized this was a man
whom you used who loved you and
worshiped you and you were pleased with
so I'm honoring him because I believe
that he is one of your Saints whom you
honored that's all I'm
doing okay okay I I'm just saying that
sometimes it's it's not it's
misunderstood be by a lot of people
because I was one of them and I was not
the only one asking for you know asking
for a miracle to the Saints praying for
them to perform perform a miracle so
were they able to perform miracles on
Earth uh yeah but it was not them
actually it was through Jesus what do
you I mean sorry sorry it was Jesus that
might used them the disciples okay say
it again I want you go with it yeah who
used
that it was Jesus who gave him the power
to do them give you 10 million bucks you
ask any Catholic if they believe that a
saint does the miracle on their own
power so you don't understand the
Catholic faith probably not but but
probably not but my point here is that
you I know I understand what you're
saying but it's there's a lot of Mis
misunderstanding in the Catholic Church
before you tell me what you think is
wrong with the Catholic church can you
explain to me how the bones of a dead
man Elisha was used by God to resurrect
the Dead Man 2 Kings 13:20 to 21 this is
your Bible right Elisha died 2 Kings 13
2021 and was buried now moabit Raiders
used to enter the country Every Spring
once while some Israelites were bearing
a man suddenly they saw a band of
Raiders so they threw the man's body
into Elisha's tomb when the body touched
Elisha's Bones the man came to life and
stood upon her feet please explain to me
how is it the bones of a dead Prophet
caus the dead man to come to life if I
follow your logic that God doesn't use
the icons or the clothing or even the
body parts of his Saints to do
Miracles explain it to me this is Bible
I didn't give you tradition
I I mean I I can't explain it let me
give you another one because you won't
be able to if you believe in the Bible
here's another one acts
54-6 nevertheless more and more men and
women believe in the Lord and were added
to their number as a result people
brought the sick into the streets and
laid them on beds and Matt so that
Peter's Shadow might fall on some of
them as he passed by please explain to
me how is the shadow of pet Peter
healing people
let me finish crowds gathered also from
towns around Jerusalem bringing their
sick and those tormented of impure
spirits and all of them were healed how
in the world does the bones of a dead
Prophet cause a dead man to be raised to
life how in the world does the shadow of
Peter heal people and cast out demons
one more example before you answer did
it I'm sorry but didn't a woman touch
the clothes of Peter and she was
instantly healed too that was yeah was
the woman who bleeding touched the
clothes of Jesus but yeah the point is
Peter too had that same ability why not
because he had the power Christ gave him
the power to do it correct so when the
saints are doing Miracles no Catholic
thinks they're doing by their power
Christ is working through that Saint
even now in heaven he doesn't stop
working through them but here Acts 19
11-2 God did extraordinary Miracles
through Paul so that even handkerchiefs
and aprons that had touched them were
taken to the sick and their illnesses
were C cured and the evil spirits left
them explain to me how does Paul's
handkerchief do a miracle or the aprons
that he
wore no I can't so when you tell me you
think you know the Bible in Catholic
Church as well as you do I'm saying
humbly out of respect because you're a
mother and I want to respect you as a
mother you don't know the Bible that
well and you don't understand what
Catholics believe so you owe it to
yourself instead of arguing let me
listen
let me hear Let me see what they have to
say and once you've understood then say
I don't accept it because you see I gave
you verses in the Bible you didn't know
they were in the Bible did you